I want to start with the current
president did you see the video when he
fell and did you see the video he
actually said uh by the way I met with
um who are those guys that are going to
fly over shortly yeah yeah that's your
president uh right now not too good
it's sad it's sad it's not you know it's
uh they're representing we are all
representing the country you've become
president and uh you're sort of not
allowed to do that but it's happened
it's happened and it's happened pretty
badly we won't go into it but we all
know the ones in the uh they count those
acts you know they never forget but that
was a bad fall you know I remember they
made remember the media made so much you
I think you're at West Point at the time
yeah and you're coming down a ramp it
didn't have a rail you had dress shoes
on like you have now which have very
slippery Souls they look a little better
but you better not walk in the rain
that's true especially downhill on a
ramp
um you know it was very interesting I
think I made my best speech that was my
best speech and I was so proud of it it
was pouring it was
and
I said this speech was so good and then
I said how do I get down sir you have to
go down the ramp I said the same when I
came up it was a long like an ice
skating rink and they said yes sir and I
had the general next to me the
commandant of cadets nice guy big guy
strong guy I said General uh and he's
wearing combat boots they don't slip too
much I said General get ready because I
may have to grab you here but I said I'm
not falling there's no way so I'd go
Tippy Toe down the thing that was a
mistake because it didn't look so good I
even agree it wasn't it but I got killed
and they never covered that speech I
said it was my bed someday they'll let a
hundred years they're going to put that
speech on I I really but uh you can't
fall you just can't fall no matter what
just can't allow it to happen then I
better not allow especially after saying
this I'd better not allow it to happen
with me
but things like that do happen so hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else